how do you handle it when someone up the
chain of command beat raise trust mmm
like what is this like lying they lied
you or this could be this is a huge this
is a huge spectrum okay then so for
number one you just learned right you
just learn something about someone's
character who now kind of know better
what you're dealing with now if this is
a major situation you might have to
immediately confront it and or go above
them in the chain of command I mean if
there's lives at risk if there's
something morally wrong that is
happening if there's something illegal
that's happening that now you're going
to get wrapped into and that's another
decision you got to make if you're not
gonna be wrapped into it then its
decision you got to make if you want to
ruin this person's life whatever that's
that's a different decision that's not
this question we'd have to deal with
that the separate question are innocent
people being hurt so if if it's
something like that lives at risk
you know something morally wrong is
happening something illegal is happening
innocent people being hurt then you're
probably going to have to say something
you're gonna have to say something
mm-hmm
now I will tell you this before you say
something make sure all your ducks in a
row make sure you have evidence don't go
off half-cocked be ready because people
that are deceitful like this they they
prepare they are ready for battle to
protect themselves and they don't care
what happens to other people so you got
to watch out for that now if it's
something really if it's something minor
you know if it's something minor then
that's something that you log down and
in the brain right and something that
you log down in the brain and um but it
allows you to see person's character and
that means again it's a minor infraction
but it also means you got to watch
yourself and you got to watch them a
little bit more closely mm-hmm you got
to be careful because people like that
they think they're smarter than everyone
else they think that they're getting
away with lies so they think they're
smarter there's like a little hint of
sociopath
in there that they can get away with
these lies and so you got to watch them
you got to watch them carefully
in in like I said it kind of goes back
to that previous question because you
don't want to be a person that comes
across as dishonest yourself and if
people don't think they can trust what
you're saying they're not going to trust
you with other things so if you know I'm
not giving you good feedback because I'm
too nice hmm
you're not going to start your you're
not going to respect my opinion anymore
right so you know when you're when
you're dealing with someone if someone
comes to you instead of again this is
honesty versus dishonesty if you come to
me and say hey what do you think of this
plan I'm not gonna say I think that's a
stupid plan I might say I don't know if
that's how I do it I might try this
approach right you're just gonna be
diplomatic if you if I'm not gonna say
to you I I don't think you're smart
enough to figure this out I want to move
you to a different division because I
don't think you're smart enough to have
solved this problem I'm not gonna say
that I'm gonna say you know what I need
you on this other project over here that
I think you're gonna be really knock
this thing out of the park
mmm no you're gonna know deep inside but
it's called tact and that's what you
have to use but back to the honesty or
when person betrays your trust you've
learned you've learned about their
character if it's a big thing you're
gonna have to talk about you're gonna
have to tell somebody
yeah it's a little thing you got to
watch right